yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah it's a little bit green I know but
I'm currently in the middle of recording
some stuff so I have the green screen on
okay so FM deck on deck oh no he's
playing them yeah yeah Guren can be door
can you see I'm kind of unsure always
about them about the names to be
perfectly honest yeah Black is fine in
this position but it is difficult to win
this is the thing this is completely
define that was this gambit line in
terms of white playing for an advantage
but it's difficult for black to do
anything at all you will quite often
just be yeah be very equal so let's see
if I can do something 95 is
unfortunately very lame maybe I can take
you and unbalance a little little but
please check but it is it is very equal
issue let's keep it a little bit on the
board I might be slightly worse here by
the way but in order to to get something
you need to sometimes put a little bit
of risk into the position try to play
the other book to be one now he might
have d5 here
to a three that makes sense
absolutely absolutely makes sense man
yeah taking on c3 did unbalance a
position but not it but not in my favor
okay
not quite sure what Bishop f4 is about
I don't mind you maybe put it on d6
maybe I can get him to move now this is
okay for me I think God 94 now as an
additional idea he can't play Bishop e3
is still of course not worse at all but
I feel I'm basically okay now yeah the
rook is attacked oh yeah so maybe go
here
the detects the Jeep on it also prevents
G form
let's see what he plays I mean I
attention he have a night moved to d4 if
he neglects that square or to d6
attacking taking the pawn so let's see
what he does he has to allow one of them
yeah now this is actually a temple on
the pond and 94 doesn't net all that
much hmm I need to try to trade the c2
rook maybe rook to be true would be nice
[Music]
I hope to be - it just plays rook D -
hmm it's not good okay so this one and
maybe rook c3 and then 94 huh some
really tough to do anything here Roxy
394 I mean it's tough - yeah oh it's
really tough to make anything happen
maybe it still this move Bishop c5 94 is
kind of a kind of amusing
I came King III though huh hmm I did not
really think about King ds3 that said
sets a bit sad but I must what I allowed
him yeah we're trying to do something
you shouldn't
blonde 8 all the way now I cannot cover
the porn and fortunately hmm it's very
sad I mean losing this position is
previous a bit off already because well
kind of I was the one trying to do stuff
okay okay so it's really tough to have
to continue here even
yeah well so let's to do a technical job
here it is maybe not super easy in a
blitz game check ok
yeah still not much fun to put it put it
mildly this is a derivative fault I
don't know it's probably bad either way
check check
yeah this is the thing you will get get
this time warning that's not good
check check
yeah
so I'll get a drawing position at the
end check check draw offered stopped and
drawing them in the only guys who love
chess but in my school of chess it is
jam now I didn't do that all that well I
tried to do you try to create some
imbalance to try to play for winning
didn't really work out all that well you
had the CAPTCHA I don't know if it is a
good idea I mean it's probably still
equal as she rabbits the way it turned
out I got into trouble so I'm kind of
okay up to here but I think what I did
now was wrong this is this kind of play
you know now I simply didn't didn't see
this correctly King III after that I'm
in trouble I'm okay I think if I had
do this he still cannot take it's
probably cool
I mean it's auntie em I mean just in
deep trouble it's it's difficult to to
give me I think to give me some advice
it just just doesn't look good here King
XIII was stronger yeah not the pants he
actually felt I have some decent chances
to make me draw the points feel
relatively weak ish and now 'taking was
maybe even better
check-check
mmm yeah I probably have enough
counterplay probably have enough
counterplay yeah the opening here this
is this is the this is the so-called can
make a defense to this opening it's a
super solid but it's tough to to witness
we have experience he actually was more
in trouble than anything else okay guys
thanks for watching